Замість пластикового водійського посвідчення і свідоцтва про реєстрацію
транспортного засобу - електронні документи у смартфоні.
У ці дні тисячі українців у різних регіонах тестують
бета-версію мобільного додатку, який дозволяє
створити електронну копію прав та техпаспорту.
Серед тих, хто одним із перших завантажив на телефон електронні документи – Павло Бєлоусов.
Я переважно користуюся електронними сервісами
і намагаюся відмовитися від будь-яких паперових речей, тому що це незручно,
це треба пам’ятати, де воно лежить, де воно загубилось і так далі.
Разом з тим жодного разу я не виходив з дому без телефону
і щоби на ньому не було інтернету.
Тому з додатком це набагато простіше.
На завантаження додатку і реєстрацію в системі Павло витратив менше хвилини.
Майже одразу дав зворотній зв'язок службі технічної підтримки.
По-перше, в мене не підтягнулася фотографія,
що мало би статися, тому що в мене
свіже водійське посвідчення.
Друге, що я повідомив, - про те,
що коли на додаток встановлений пароль і подивитися ці запущені додатки,
мала би бути прихована ця інформація.
Користувачів багато, проблем різних багато.
Я думаю, що купа всього, чого не очікували розробники,
вони знайдуть і матимуть, над чим працювати.
Усього на тестування бета-версії додатку зареєструвалися майже 60 тисяч водіїв.
Пробний період користування електронними правами й техпаспортом
для них триватиме приблизно місяць.
У цей час можна вже не мати при собі пластикових документів,
їх онлайн-аналоги є повноцінною альтернативою.
Виняток - перетин кордону, для цього слід мати традиційні документи.
Міністр цифрової трансформації Михайло Федоров пояснює:
тестовий період необхідний, аби удосконалити абсолютну новий
для держави формат онлайн-сервісу.
Наші реєстри, де зберігаються дані українців,
вони просто не готові до такого промислового запуску.
Тому ми запустили таке бета-тестування.
Ми хочемо, щоб 20 тисяч українців
почали використовувати,
ми будемо дивитися, як їм зручно,
що в цей час відбувається з реєстром,
і потім ми поправимо помилки, якщо вони будуть,
і запустимо масштабно на всю країну.
Однак навіть після повноцінного запуску онлайн-прав
скористатися цією послугою зможуть не всі.
Основна умова - водійське посвідчення має бути нового зразка -
це пластикова картка з фото.
Такі є лише у кожного четвертого українського водія.
Аби збільшити кількість тих, хто зможе скористатися цією цифровою послугою,
фотографії і дані взяли також з інших реєстрів.
Тож, розраховують загалом на 5,5 мільйонів потенційних користувачів -
це дещо більше половини.
Я сам працюю в ІТ-сфері і розумію, що все, що переходить в цифровий режим, завжди плюс.
Звичайно, єдиний момент, як нам це вирішити
зі старшим населенням.
Навіть якщо факт мого порушення правил буде недоведений,
просто просто електронне вилучення і все, хоча насправді я не був винний.
А так коли воно в мене в руці, я можу сказати -
ні, ви не праві. Правильно?
Якщо це полегшить завдання нашим органам
і полегшить життя водіям, то я тільки "за".
Українські водії цьогоріч майже 170 тисяч разів
порушили правила дорожнього руху, бо їхали
без прав чи техпаспорту.
У Міністерстві внутрішніх справ кажуть: тепер патрульні попереджені
про водіїв з електронними посвідченнями
і готові до роботи з ними.
Поліцейський буде перевіряти... дані
документи в електронному вигляді,
тобто або за допомогою планшету,
як це буде на першому етапі,
або в майбутньому зможе перевірити це
за допомогою свого мобільного пристрою,
якщо буде в цьому потреба.
Тестовий період використання електронних документів,
окрім виявлення технічних недоліків роботи додатку,
повинен відповісти на низку запитань, як-от:
як каратимуть тих, у кого розрядиться телефон з онлайн-документами?
Або якщо власника електронних прав не знайшли в електронному реєстрі?
Та як позбавлятимуть права водити автомобіль власників
електронних документів, які грубо порушили правила дорожнього руху?
Ще один важливий фактор - безпека даних.
У міністерстві цифрової трансформації стверджують:
приватна інформація користувачів додатку зашифрована і фактично в ньому не зберігається.
Втім, на думку експертів,
певні ризики завжди існують.
Наскільки я знаю, система, яка
пропонується зараз міністерством цифрової політики,
по суті, не створює ніяких нових реєстрів,
використовує існуючі реєстри.
Теоретично якісь витоки інформації можуть бути,
але на практиці достатньо захищені.
І ця інформація буде передаватися саме на ваш смартфон.
Насправді такі ризики є скрізь, і багато європейських країн
трохи затягували з моментом імплементації електронних посвідчень
саме через те, що вони хвилювалися за захищеність системи.
Електронні водійські посвідчення та технічні паспорти дали старт
мобільному додатку "Дія" - це, по суті,
і є "держава в смартфоні".
Додаток за шість тижнів і без залучення бюджетних грошей
розробила і передала Міністерству цифрової трансформації міжнародна IT компанія.
нтерфейс "Дії" дозволить у майбутньому
додавати до нього
дедалі більше державних онлайн-послуг.
Ми привчаємо людей, що вони повинні знати, що знає про них держава.
Тому що у наступних релізах буде можливість, коли ви реєструєтеся,
це дуже швидко, 7 секунд,
ви бачите нерухомість, якою ви володієте,
ви бачите землю, якою ви володієте, ви бачите автомобілі,
ви бачите всі документи, якими ви володієте.
І якщо щось трапляється, ви можете швидко заблокувати,
швидко замовити нові документи, ви отримаєте сповіщення,
що, наприклад, у вас змінюється власник квартири або бізнесу.
У Міністерстві цифрової трансформації анонсують:
після успішного старту першого сервісу, наступні будуть з’являтися мало не щомісяця.
Одразу за водійськими правами обіцяють електронний студентський квиток,
а згодом і паспорт громадянина України.
Втім, на повне оцифрування можуть піти роки.
Адже українські реєстри часто мають застарілу, неповну чи некоректну інформацію,
яку потрібно перевірити і систематизувати.
Інша важлива умова використання мобільного додатку "Дія" - наявність смартфону.
За оцінками, гаджетами нині зовсім не користуються
майже половина дорослих українців,
більшість із них - люди похилого віку.